Je n'ai pas de problème, monsieur, je ne veux pas mettre
en place une nouvelle commande à Césarée, nouvelle
ville de mobilité vers l'étape 5 émerger Hadi vient de
libérer votre vin de nourriture autorisé risotto un
sachet de tératome ces artistes Oh parlez-le
rangez-le le jour de votre vie elle fait un
une tasse de café mais je raconte une histoire - Iggy
- Zoop Alma nove est une leçon à - -
halète oh ceux qui sont un pauvre ouvrier mais qui
n'ont jamais pu était habanero ne voient pas un Tucson
la sécurité vient est Wesley eh bien allons-y
je peux utiliser un  cheveux Nikola viens fume
à travers
ouais - un bateau comme toi je peux essayer de nager
dans l'eau tu vois quelqu'un je suis debout
avec toi un jour nous nous sommes rencontrés au-dessus de ton abri je
ne sais pas encore la réflexologie elle a eu de
la chance tu en as un au beurre  minute Monet
ne touche plus professeur 20e
siècle-renard un studio ciel bleu présent J'ai
aussi rencontré la sauce une oie noire mal
sivle Malda Omega Sammy parler de poche une
certaine stratégie soulève facilement
de leprechaun Sivaji le devoir Tom je
ne fais pas eBay hé c'est
réalisé étonné que vous ayez consulté
un orignal aujourd'hui juste pour que l'argent soit prêt à
être un speci moi beaucoup d'armée célèbre
/ j'enseigne le bazar s'emballe ici
quelques jours mobile juste un petit jour de mariage en verre
Lou Treasury ouais Oh le cinéma
est-ce que ça ressemble à un problème pour  vous
là, elle est la mère de tous les astéroïdes
qui crient vers nous, cher esprit,
nous sommes proches de l'extinction, mais pas de soucis,
cette tablette détient la clé, nous allons sur ce
site de crash, recherchez des indices cosmiques,
puis découvrez comment l'arrêter
qui est assez stupide pour  pense qu'ils peuvent empêcher
un astéroïde de s'écraser hé se présenter au
devoir à la fin de l'ère glaciaire pendant que
vous courez pour sauver votre vie, vous serez haut dans
le ciel en sécurité comme ces birdies chanceux ont tiré
maintenant garçon il n'est que le début quel est
cet endroit
épicé je  suis de toute façon le secret pour sauver
le monde il est ici gen Manama pouvez-vous
avoir tous oui mais d'abord mon chien
poulet funky jiggy jelly muscat pourriez-vous
m'aider s'il vous plaît
mon nez est dangereusement proche de mon mais
II de la vingtième siècle Fox et
des studios blue sky d'accord  faisons-le
ce sont les gars qui vont sauver
le monde nous avons l'air si cool comme un ninja
c'est pas nul c'était une stratégie le
chapitre déterminant a gardé des super pouvoirs
le plus grand chilla G de tous les temps tu es
le vent sous mes pieds le LG de  mon
œil et j'ai des papillons je deviens
nauséeux
attrape mon pote mammifère ça ne marchera jamais
accroche toi à tes fesses on va
arrêter ce truc avec une mousse de tomate